[Music]
this is a big big problem if you think
somebody's going to hurt themselves ask
the question
are you thinking about hurting yourself
are you thinking about killing yourself
practice that question i asked somebody
that i love not a family member that
question this week
[Music]
what's up what's up what's up this is
john with the dr john dolone show
so glad you're hanging out with us today
for a really important show
have a really important show today if
you want to be on the show in the future
man i'd love to have you give me a call
at
nine three 1-844-693-30 two ninety one
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one to go to
johndaloni.com
ask today's an important show it's uh
you know the one of the themes of this
show is having hard conversations
and
um whether it's sex and intimacy whether
it's talking to your kids about hard
things whatever it happens to be
um i think one of the challenges we have
in the world right now is that we avoid
hard conversations we just hope stuff
will go away
or we don't want to deal with it and we
don't want to deal with hard stuff
and i've just committed my life to
helping people have hard conversations
and walk through hard stuff so today's a
hard show today is a really important
show and so i hope you'll stay with us
for the entire show all the way through
the end
um and be sensitive to the little ears
in the room but this is an important
show and i'm gonna talk to some real
folks who have some real struggles and
then we're gonna talk at the end about
some things that we can all do together
so let's start us out let's go to louisa
in denver colorado luisa what's going on
so i
am calling because i lost my
sorry let me try to get through this no
you're good you're hey louis
take your time okay take your time okay
i lost my
16 year old son to suicide um 29 months
ago
and
i just can't seem to get past
the grief
the pain
the guilt um
and i just i don't i don't know what to
do i don't know how to move forward
um i feel like i take steps forward and
then just go right back to
day one yeah
i'm so sorry what was his name
police louise how old was he he was 16
you said 16.
um
tell me what happened
um
louis suffered from mental illness um
depression anxiety ptsd
um
but
you know we were doing all the things um
therapy
had
support at school
had support at home
um
and just
the morning of his death
um him and i got in a huge fight
um
and you know i can't even remember the
details of the argument
um
he had spent some time with his dad that
morning and um
then we were leaving for a birthday
party and he didn't want to go
well you know wanted to do his own thing
and it just
snowballed quickly very very quickly and
screaming and yelling and
i told him you know what we're gonna go
we're gonna do our own thing you say you
go do your thing your dad's coming for
you
you know do your thing and
we left and i have two younger
children who left with me
and we got home and
found him yeah
golly
you saw something that no mother's ever
ever supposed to see or experience
i'm so so sorry
wow
[Music]
and so walk me through what's been
life's been like the last
two and a half years now or two plus
years
um
it's very hard because i'm
i'm a school counselor oh geez
you're supposed to know all the answers
louisa i should know all of that right
like i should have saved him
i should have been able to
keep him alive that's my job as a mom
that's my job as a mental health
professional
and so that's where a lot of the guilt
comes from
is i should have known and
did better
and
i feel like i did it and
um
i try now to just
it's very hard working with other kids
um in the same situation or similar
situations
um and it
constantly re-traumatizes me
my little ones are doing okay
but i feel like my job is to make sure
they're supported and they're they're
taken care of they have the therapy they
have the support
um
i also have a 21 year old son and
i feel like my job is to protect him now
so it's just it's hard i struggle every
day with making decisions
um
just knowing what to do not breaking
down in front of my children
not breaking down in front of students i
work with
yeah um
so
man there's so much and if i if i was
with you right now
with your permission of course i would
hug you for the next 10 minutes and not
say a word um you've probably had plenty
of well-meaning yet
painful
recommendations and advice and little
pithy things given to you over the last
couple of years
and you've probably looked at all the
blogs and all the
you know the
books and all the stuff right have you
got counseling on your own
um i did in the beginning and then i
stopped because
i had to take care of every video yeah
man
so
i don't want to presume that to just
jump in here and start throwing stuff at
you so
um
how can i walk alongside with you in
this i've got a thousand things circling
through my head but i want to know what
you need right now
i guess my biggest thing is like
i know what i need to do right like i
know i need the therapy
i know i need to take care of myself
um
but i don't know how to do that i don't
know how to
stay on track with anything
i
don't know how to commit to anything
um
so how do i do that how do i
make a commitment to
start therapy again how do i
i don't know i don't even know where to
start or what to do or
um
the conversation we're about to have is
better had in person okay
and you're you're a mental health
professional i'm just a pretend guy on
the radio right on a podcast but
this conversation's better had in person
but we're gonna have it over the phone
is that okay yeah okay
um
a couple things i'm hearing that i want
to jump in the middle of
okay
and some of this you know what i'm about
to say i'm gonna say it anyway because
you gotta hear it okay and this is
probably the same stuff you've told
parents
in your career
probably better than i'm gonna tell you
but your son
passing is not your fault
and
you've beat up my friend louisa for two
and a half years now
and
you can't fully help your kids that are
still with you you can't fully honor
luis's memory you can't fully
uh help the kids that you help at school
until you stop beating up yourself
till you forgive you set stuff down
and breathe
okay
until you believe
and don't just say it out loud but until
you believe that you're worth being
loved you're worth being okay
you're not this stuff's gonna stay this
close to the surface and you think all
this is about him right now but it's not
it's about you right now
how many times have you replayed that
morning
in the last two years
oh
daily yeah exactly
and your body has spent the last two and
a half years looking for every possible
possible moment this could happen again
and you haven't taken a full breath in
two years
is that true
yes yeah
and your identity as a mom was shattered
your identity as a counselor was
shattered your identity as a protector
and a provider was shattered
and all that's true
and so healing moving forward is
is
about building a new identity about
living into something new and and
until you stop trying to regain what was
and start living into what is and what
will be
my friend you're it's gonna you're gonna
feel like you're treading water in a
really rough seas
and every third breath you're gonna be
breathing in water
do you believe this is your fault
be honest be honest
yes
have you ever heard me lie to anybody
no
okay i'm not starting today it's not
your fault
it's not your fault
your son was hurting for a long long
time
and i don't think that he wanted to die
i think he wanted to stop hurting
and one of the great demons of
the great great lies of a mind that is
struggling with
suicide is
they believe they're a burden to other
people and they look for every possible
shred of evidence to back that story up
it becomes a vacuum right
and
he turned a
saturday morning spat
that every mom and every son and every
parent and every kid and every brother
and every sister and every coworker have
into
a story that it wasn't
and it's not because he was trying to be
ugly or means because he was wasn't well
great
and like the mother who's driving down
the road
five five miles an hour below the speed
limit and the kid runs out in front of
the car
the car hit him but that wasn't her
fault
and this was the fight
the yelling the the permanent solution
to a short-term problem is not on on you
and if nothing else in this phone call i
want you to hear me tell you i love you
your kids love you
and this is not your fault
will you say those words out loud
this is not my fault
thank you
and you said it with a question mark at
the end of it but i'll let it go this
time okay
so
in my work in crisis work one of the
things i
ran up on that surprised me and you've
talked about on this show several times
is i ran up against my own limitations
which i didn't know existed
when i got called to a few scenes that
involved young children and i had a
baby little girl and i left
and i found there was a limit
and so as we walk through what do you do
next what does healing look like for you
moving forward
how do you get the gumption to even take
care of yourself
um
i want you to keep in mind that for a
season
i had to not be in that environment with
that particular group of people so that
i could heal yeah
and it may mean that for the next two
years three years five years one
semester whatever that looks like
that
working in mental health with
teenage kids
is going to prohibit you from
healing that doesn't mean it's a forever
thing in fact i don't think it's for
everything in fact i think you become
one of the most powerful voices in the
country on this
but you gotta heal first
you can't show your scar around you
can't you can't show your scars and talk
about your scars while they're still
bleeding
and so healing
in this in your walk starts with you
even thinking you're worth healing
because right now you don't
you think you're a mom that failed you
think you're a mental health
professional that failed and until you
think you're worth
breathing again and smiling again and
sleeping again and laughing again until
you believe that
your body's gonna keep
going to war with you
and so
i've heard it
multiple ways and i don't care which way
you find it
because right now you're still in
survival mode
i've had veterans tell me that
they got home and lost some of their
their partners on the battlefield
that every day of their life is in
memory of in service to those who didn't
come home great
i've heard people who lose a child say
i'm going to stand up and live for me
because i deserve it great
i'm going to live
for my i'm going to make meaning of this
i'm not going to let my child have
passed in vain i'm going to make sure
that there's no more drunk drivers in
the road that no more young kids take
their life whatever whatever this looks
like that that my kid no other kid ever
gets cancer like my kid did
i don't care how you do it or why you do
it but you've got to have an arrow that
you are pointing towards
you got to have a marker somewhere and
it will change over time but you got to
have something that says this is the
light worth getting out of bed for
because right now your light that you're
getting out of bed for is a
is not true it's a bunch of shoulds
and you thought you should have
protected him and now you're just
hell-bent on protecting everybody else
to the point that you're neglecting
yourself and probably suffocating them a
bit is that fair
fair
very fair
here's what really sucks is it's been
two years
and i don't think you've grieved yet
i think you've been hurting like bloody
hell for two years but i don't think
you've started grieving yet
and this is gonna be the hardest thing i
say on this whole call and i'll get
choked up here if i'm not careful
there's gonna have to come a moment when
you forgive louise
and there's gonna have to come a moment
when you tell louise that i love you and
there's gonna have to come a moment when
you open your hands and let luis go
and no mama ever
ever ever should have to let her baby go
and that doesn't have to be the day they
didn't have to be tomorrow that i have
to be in three four weeks
but until you let luis go not that
you're not gonna remember them not that
you're still gonna have photos up of
course you're gonna have those things of
course you're gonna develop a
scholarship for him and you're gonna
give a talk to a local school about kids
and mental health you're gonna do those
things his memory will stay alive
but you're still sitting in the floor of
your home hugging his body
right
yeah
just like haven't been able to separate
yeah that
of like
yes his memory still lives on but i
can't let him go that's right
and this is one of those things man that
you i know listeners probably this time
who listened to this conversation rolled
their eyes at this point but at some
point
you write him his long his letter his
goodbye letter
have you done that yet
no
no
and as a mental health professional you
know that's what you got to do
but you got to tell him goodbye
and whether you go out to his grave and
you read it to him
or you write it and you take it out to
the lake and
let it out into the water whatever that
looks like for you
but you're gonna have to tell him you're
sorry you're gonna tell me forgive him
you're gonna tell me you love him
you have to tell him that you're going
to do your best you you can to make
meaning of what happened and
live
and that you're going to laugh again and
you're going to smile again and you're
going to find joy again whatever that
looks like
and that's going to be years and years
and years
so here's a couple of things that you
said that i want to make sure i touch on
okay and i know right now you may not
even be hearing me anymore
um
but i want you to go back and have this
to listen to and also the people
listening okay
it's really important that you don't
hide your grief from your other kids
because they feel it at different levels
too
and they need to know that mom that
they're not crazy and that mom's not a
robot
and so if they come in
and you are it's right up there on the
surface
or his birthday comes up
or christmas happens and there's not a
stocking on the wall with his name on it
and you just have one of those or
one of those moments you just
come out of the bathroom and it hits you
um
and one of your kids is with you and
you're on the floor
curled up weeping
let your kids come hug you don't hide
that from them
and if they say what's wrong mama what's
wrong say i really really miss
louise
i miss him today
say the words out loud grief demands a
witness
and you're not protecting them by hiding
from them okay
okay
here's the second thing
i don't know what you think you're
supposed to be feeling right now but
grief is this is from
kessler's work man grief is as unique as
your fingerprint
there's no right way to do this you do
have to keep
paying your bills and you do have to
keep eating and you do have to keep
moving your body and you do have mouths
to feed in your home
but you're allowed to hurt
and you're allowed to feel like you are
under water
and you're allowed to wake up on
saturdays and say i just can't do it
today
that's when the hard work you have to do
is to make sure you've got somebody you
can call that will come pick up your
kids and go play
is that fair
can't do this by yourself
the journey moving forward is having a
light having a purpose having a reason
you may have to take some time for
healing and then go back to work
maybe you have to switch to the
classroom work in the lunchroom i don't
care be an administrator i don't know
whatever what i know that every state's
different with how they are able to move
people around but it may just be a
season where you need some healing
and you'll come back strong or you say
dude i'm out of this i'm going to start
a lawn business i don't i don't know
right
but
i threw a lot of stuff at you tell me
where your heart's at right now
obviously you don't feel better and i
knew that in this phone call and
obviously you don't have all your
answers but
tell me what's going on in your heart
and mine
i'm sorry um
i
just um that's i think a big part of why
i reached out to you as well is because
i'm really struggling with
leaving the profession
in general
um as part of my healing and
taking a different route
to
just
heal
in a different way and to help people
in a different way not the mental health
aspect but a different way and um
so this is good to hear for my
own
journey um here's who you are louisa you
are someone who helps other people
yeah and if i got fired tomorrow if i
lost my job if nobody listened to this
podcast ever again
and i started working at burger king
i would be somebody who wanted to help
people there
yeah and if i went to be an elementary
school teacher again like i did one year
one chaotic crazy year
i would want to help those kids and if i
went back to teaching high school or uh
being a college professor i'd be a
helper that's just what i do and that's
who you are
um i don't think you're done forever
it sounds like a
that as close as your profession is
to what the hurt that you have
um it seems like a break makes sense
and it might be two months that might be
three months that might not be forever
it may look totally different but you're
going to be someone who loves and serves
and helps other people
i can't think of a better thing for you
to do
than to get with a group of moms who've
had your experience there in denver
colorado
and
the idea of that on the outside sounds
like hell and i know that the last thing
you'd want to do is go have this
conversation with 15 other people
grief demands a witness
somebody has to hear your story which
means you have to speak your story out
loud
and other moms who have been down the
road a little bit further than you and a
lot of other moms who are logistics just
are still
raw um that's what healing looks like
and all you throw dads and their parents
in there
you understand this intellectually and
your body is overwhelmed
you experience something that the human
body is not designed to experience
no parent should find their child who's
passed away
no
parent should hug their child who's
passed away no parent should bury a
child
it's not the way this thing works
and so the healing out of this is going
to be unique and it's going to take
other people and it's going to take a
mission of some sort
before i before i let you go will you
say i'm worth being well i want to hear
you say those words
i'm worth being well
and i'm worth being loved
and i'm worth being loved and i'm worth
laughing one day
and i'm worth laughing one day
and i love my baby boy
and they love my baby boy
and it wasn't my fault
and it wasn't my fault
you're a brave brave sister and thank
you so much for sharing your journey
with us
please please please please please make
a call today
make one call to a group and say today's
the day
circle your kids up and say hey mom's
been really struggling with
with brothers death even though it was
two years ago i'm still struggling big
time and i will be for a long time
someone's all that i know
today's the day thank you so much so
sorry that your son passed away i'm so
sorry that
you're hurting like you have been your
family's hurt
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
it won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get ten percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to
lindsay in louisville kentucky hey
lindsay what's up
hey john how are you we are we are
making it work today how are you
that was heavy that was heavy stuff yeah
so for the listener um
lindsey's been on hold on on the line on
hold and so you you you heard via
telephone that last phone call there
um yeah this heavy heavy episode today
so tell us what's going on in your world
well um
man
i just i want to give her a hug and i
want you to tell i want to tell you to
hang up with me and call her back but um
[Music]
man
i my question is um
how i can help my
13 year old daughter who
is navigating through
losing a friend to suicide
[Music]
um so what happened yeah what happened
um
this was not
this wasn't a bestie of hers
it was someone that she had several
classes with
someone that she considered a friend at
school
they were math partners
and
he uh from what i understand shot
himself
okay
and um
he was he actually initially lived
and
so he was in icu
um for a couple of days so
all the kids knew that um
so it was almost like
them
reliving it
twice yeah i mean held your daughter
13. oh geez yeah that 13 year old gossip
rumor milled i heard what happened can
you believe just been something fierce
yeah what a mess yeah
okay ultimately he passed away so
what what how has she been at home
she um
it's been it's been about a month since
then so um
we've seen a drastic difference in her
um
she went through a really hard week i
mean that first week was just really
really tough um
she kind of has transitioned into this i
want to help everybody
and i want to make sure nobody else is
going through a hard time
and um
i don't know maybe that means she's
going to be a therapist one day
um
but i you know i just i still worry
about her sure i mean she sat she just
two days ago sat with a friend um her
friend asked her to sit with her in the
counseling office because
she's had some of those same thoughts
and stuff going through her mind yep
and um i can just feel the weight yeah
okay
so i'll start it with this
our kids can only be as well as we are
right and so
anytime our 13 year olds i got a 12 year
old in my house anytime our 13 year olds
or 12 year olds or 16 year olds our nine
year olds
are struggling
the first place we parents gotta go is
the mirror
and make sure we're okay
what does okay mean that means
you would be
pathological you would be psychotic if
you didn't immediately go what if that
was my kid
right um
as mom what did i miss
or i can't believe his mom what do i do
i don't know what i should be doing
should we do something right all those
things
and
for some of us that makes us reach for
one more bowl of ice cream or two more
drinks or we turn the tv up a little bit
more or we stare at our phones a little
bit more
some of some of it is drastic it reminds
us of somebody we lost five years ago 10
years ago 25 years ago right
all that to say is
parents we got to go to the mirror first
and make sure we're modeling what grief
should look like
and i hate shoulds most of the time not
all the time there's some really
important shoulds but this is an
important one
and this is when you know we're watching
natural disasters or war whatever when
we have trauma
kids look to us for how am i supposed to
respond to this
so
here's a couple of things you know this
but i'll just
just to make sure and i've been with
this i've been through this at the high
school level i've been through this
personally i've been through this at the
you know college level and beyond so
there's something incredibly visceral
for a kid when they look over and
there's an empty seat
it's a reminder it's a it's a story that
their bodies are not prepared for
adults have
multiple we get we experience more loss
whether directly or peripherally right
we we understand this there's something
when that first 13 year old looks over
in the classroom there's an empty seat
there's a black hole there that is
indescribable they don't have words for
it
um most of us don't have words for it
and i'm going to get choked up thinking
about some of the students that i've
lost and buried and done their funerals
for them
the second thing that is brutal
it that affects all of us that affected
the last caller that affects moms and
dads that affects math partners is this
haunting question what did i miss
which turns into this is my fault
if i'd only seen something if i had only
done something if i only asked something
and
here's the ugly part about that question
is sometimes there's some truth to that
i should have just asked
or i should have said something
often
not there is nothing and you know what i
mean there's nothing out there at any
any any step along the way that's a
that's a
question that bears no fruit
um i'm i'm haunted by some photos of
students that i've lost that some of the
celebrities that have passed away by
suicide the last few years
you know i'm trying to think of the one
that was the lead singers chester the
lead singer of lincoln park
chester bingfield whose wife posted a
picture and said this is
the face
of somebody um suffering from suicidal
ideation and it was her husband laughing
his head off playing with his kids like
two or three days before he took his
life
before he died by suicide and
so
to think we can guess
is often impossible if you can see
something in action you get some clear
signs we'll talk about that later on in
the show
yes there's some things you can do like
that good interventions but for most of
us man it's just our math partner just
our friend we laugh and we go about our
day i had no idea people were hurting
like they were inside
um and then like we mentioned earlier
yeah man
the stories and the rumor mills and the
he was my friend no he's my boyfriend no
i really loved him all of that oh my
it's
it's catastrophic
it's like uh social media pylons but
it's in real life you know what i mean
is in is that sweet girl just i just
imagine her just getting buried with
this you have her own guilt on top of
there's an empty seat in those classes
on top of
hey did you hear this hey i heard this i
heard his mom hey i heard you would
and for a 13 year old man i just
i just it's it's
so heavy
so heavy
so you say she had a really rough week
which is to be expected
um
here's my concern for her
her job as a 13 year old
is to make sure she's okay
and i'm i'm worried about her any 13
year olds 15 year olds 18 year olds 25
year olds
trying to
um run from
this guilt
trying to run from this empty chair into
i'm gonna solve everyone else's problems
because it keeps me from having to sit
in the fact that the world is really
hard and that sometimes people we care
about pass away
and that's where she needs you
in a real real way
um
tell me about the conversations y'all
have had about
suicide about grief about passing
um we have a pretty open line of
communication with her my
my husband is military he's lost friends
to suicide and
on the battlefield and
things like that so
he's probably been more of a help and
support to her than anything
my best friend is an lmft
oh fantastic
yes yes good
um she
we i really when i think about the
relationship that i have
with my daughter it's um
i feel like it's really great i feel
like we can talk about really anything
um
she she actually says i have a john
delony problem because i'm constantly
picking apart conversations that you've
had with callers
and she's like you may have a problem
mom you should probably go see somebody
lindsay that's not a good problem to
have
so um
she we we have talked about what death
look looks like um she did not want to
go to
um his
they had a wake for him she didn't want
to go she didn't want to deal with it
but we um we really encouraged her to go
oh thank you did she ultimately go
she did she did hey you get
you get parenting award of the year
just for that move right there
every parent listening
if your child has somebody in their life
who dies they need to go to the funeral
full stop they need to go even if they
don't want to go if they don't want to
go you go with them
and if you can't go find somebody they
need that that will be something that
reverberates through their body for
years and years and years good for you
lindsay oh so good
thank you
that was hard
that was so hard i mean i literally felt
like i was pushing her out the door
crying yeah absolutely absolutely
she went with a group of friends um her
math teacher was there which was super
helpful and i it was so great
for her to witness
others grief yeah around her it has to
have a witness that's right that's right
and um she she has talked about that um
for
i mean for the past month she's talked
about that
um she's talked about how they've kind
of been a support for each other at
school
um
she
she's kind of again she's kind of made
it her mission to help others
and she wants to help others um
and so i think the the hard part as a
parent is reining some of that in
meaning
um
she can't take uh
i i've spent my career teaching faculty
members parents administrators at school
that when a child is in need
that they need to pass that on these are
professional adults they need to turn
that over to professionals
they don't have the tools or equipment
or strengths to carry that to know what
to do next and if you don't know what
you're doing kids can get hurt right
and so the same thing applies here
and i know it's gonna read to your
daughter who's trying
her sweet little brain is trying to
solve for what happened with this will
never happen again on my watch
which means that every one of her
friends that has any sort of i'm having
dark thoughts i'm thinking about these
things
they know lindsay will show up
and lindsay's gonna get tired
you know what i mean
and so
it may mean that
when some when she comes home and says
or let's do this let's do this
preemptively so let me do this in order
here
one thing um i would with all of my
heart you've heard me talk about this in
romantic relationships with you know
with spouses and whatnot boyfriends and
girlfriends i think we should do this
here and i think it will pay you have an
opportunity to give your daughter some
tools that will
uh it's one of these change your family
tree moments okay
um
two things if you haven't already
get and this is one that even if you
can't afford it figure out and overpay
for a really cool nice
mom and daughter dad journal
and have this a dialogue where y'all
writing to one another
okay and
she can right now her 13 year old brain
plus her sadness plus her
the frenetic energy and by the way that
will fade
that energy that's just buzzing buzzing
and buzz and buzzin um
she needs to see it's gonna filter what
she hears from you and from your husband
and y'all have some great experiences
that you can pass along to her that are
important that she needs to hear
and so
um being able to write that stuff down
having your husband say i was just
thinking about my buddy
dan who died by suicide four years ago
thought about him today broke my heart i
miss him
thank you so much
sweet daughter for being so brave
missing your friend
that kind of letter
will
dramatically shift her healing but it'll
also give her
two firm feet to walk under
um
so having some or how was today and her
just writing today was a good day i feel
like i'm doing good things i'm making
meaning of this right that's a way to
y'all to connect that you think you're
connecting when you're talking to teens
and often we're not they know how to
play our games they know how to say what
we need to sit here so that we smile and
think they're doing great and they go
about their lives and so having a
dialogue there they will often write or
text things they would never say in
person and so have that open dialogue
and get your husband in on it too would
be great the second thing is
have you taken her out somewhere and
told her how much you're hurting
no don't hide that from her
i took so here's here's just a life life
example here um the ukraine invasion
happened and there was those videos of
you know parents handing their kids off
and i took my son up um and let them
know this is an important conversation i
closed i closed the guest room door
and sat down he knew i think he thought
he was in trouble and i said um tell me
what you've been hearing about what's
going on in russia and school and he
told me way more than i thought he would
have known
and i he's asked me some hard questions
and i answer them as as truthfully and
honestly as possible
and then i told him
i was weeping the other day bubba i
started crying
and he said you i said yeah i was crying
really hard actually i'm sad to pull the
car over because i was thinking about
what would happen if i had to hand you
and josephine off to mom
and y'all got in the car and just barely
escaped and i had to stay and protect
our house
and he got really solemn and i said
these are scary moments and i'm i'm i'm
scared and nobody's called me to fight
but here's some things that you and i
are going to do here's some things me
and your mommy are going to do to be in
service to our communities to be healthy
and whole around here
and so i didn't steal for i didn't want
him to think i'm a robot i don't want
him to think he's crazy for being scared
and it sounds counterintuitive that we
need to quote on quote-unquote show
strength and perseverance and concrete
you know i'm going to hide this stuff in
the bedroom
from our kids i'm going to cry in my
closet no dude invite your kids into
that not hysterics and rage and anger
but be honest with your kids about how
you're hurting it would be a gift to
your daughter if you take her out on a
special date just you two
and let her know that you couldn't help
but think what if that was my daughter
and sweetheart if you ever are
struggling
please tell me
tell your dad tell somebody at school
tell somebody
i love you
and the thought of losing you scares me
so much it breaks my heart so much and i
want you to know that i love you more
than life itself right i want you to
hold her hands when you're telling her
this stuff
i want you to know that i i could hardly
breathe when you were talking
i hurt for that guy's mother i hurt that
little boy her for all his friends let
her hear that from you
and she will
her shoulders will drop she'll realize
she's not alone in her house
and your husband can go with you
this isn't a time for lectures this is
how you should feel her grief is her
grief it's going to be different than
y'alls
let her have her feelings and
god help us middle school girls have
feelings and
middle school boys do too but
man
her know that you're walking alongside
her unless
she's lucky lucky lucky to have you
lindsay thank you so much for your call
i know there's a whole bunch of parents
out in the country millions of them that
are dealing with the same thing you're
walking through and your daughter's
lucky to have you we'll be right back
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to
greensbury.com and you'll get 10 off
your first purchase check it out today
your nutrition is worth it
all right we are back um
important show
important show
about
suicide about loss
um i got some notes here just want to
walk through some stuff and give
everybody some tips and some ideas
um during 2020
the
number of mental health emergency room
visits
among adolescents
12 to 17 right middle and high school
kids
increased over 30 percent
that's
astronomical numbers
during may of 2020 during the coveted
pandemic
it began to suicide um ideation suicide
attempts begin to increase among
adolescents middle school high school
kids especially young girls
and i've got some theories about that
i'll be for another show suspected
emergency room visits were 51 percent
higher among girls than than during the
same period in 2019
and boys um had elevated visits too
this is a big big problem
and
as a guy who's dedicated his life to
working with young people who's got two
young people in my home um i'm just a
dad man i'm just a dad trying to love my
kids and i'm just a dad who loves your
kids too
this stuff's super important so i'm
gonna run through a couple of things
here
first is here's some facts um
facts about suicide that i want us to
all know
talking about suicide does not increase
the likelihood that it's going to happen
if you think somebody's going to hurt
themselves ask the question
are you thinking about hurting yourself
are you thinking about killing yourself
practice that question
i asked somebody that i love not a
family member i asked somebody that i
love that question this week
this week
are you thinking about hurting yourself
are you going to kill yourself tell me
now
talking about it does not go oh i didn't
think about that i guess i'm going to no
talking about it pulls it out into the
open there is no risk
in having that conversation there is
risk in not having it okay
people i don't believe in they're just
faking it a hundred percent of the
people in my sphere and my circle in my
extended circle if you talk about it i'm
calling it all in
i'm calling everybody i'm calling 9-1-1
i'm calling your family
i called a
somebody who i love and care about who's
an adult i called their parents recently
70s don't care i'll call everybody
called other friends that i love and
said hey we gotta get involved in this
the majority of people at risk for
suicide
are not interested in dying
they're interested in the pain stopping
here's why that's important we always
talk about preventing suicide
but for somebody who is going to die by
suicide suicide is the solution it's not
the problem the problem is how much pain
i have
and that's a big shift in focus
and what's the pain
thomas joyner is one of the leading
suicidologists in the country he's a
brilliant professor and researcher and
writer out of
florida state
last time i looked he's at florida state
um
he says that it's a three-prong approach
these three things have to happen
two of the three things have to happen
for people to lean into suicide
one is feelings of loneliness or a
failure to belong isolation i'm out here
on an island by myself so think about
these kids that have been out of school
for a year for two years in some places
number two the capacity for self-harm
some will say cutting is not a big deal
some will say cutting is practice for
slowly learning how to hurt yourself um
i-10 my experience with cutting in teens
has been that it's it's a
um it's generally benign but it can be
it does it doesn't doesn't make me go ah
right if a teen is cutting himself but i
am going to ask questions absolutely
it's a it's a signal to me i'm going to
ask some questions
right i'm not i'm not going to lose my
mind but i am going to ask some
questions about that
but there is a
do you have the capability to
hurt yourself
right do you have the capacity for
self-harm
that could p be an extension around um
doctors who are around or first
responders who are living in the stuff
all the time all the time all the time
and then the third one is i think i
think is the big one
being a burden to others this idea that
people would be better off if i wasn't
here
so we go back to the capacity to hurt
yourself let's be real clear about this
every cell in the human body is wired
for one thing to get to tomorrow and to
get to the next day and to get to the
next day cells even have
ways that they
decompose
so that other cells can use them to get
to the next day and get to the next day
so to override your system
at the cellular level to die by suicide
is a huge task
huge
it's not something that's just oh oh
it's not
it's not weakness
it's not failure
it's hurt it's pain it's illness
okay
so um people at risk for suicide may
give clues and signals they may give
away stuff
often if somebody makes a decision
there's a there's often a discussion
about man for the last two weeks they've
just been super happy
because they've been hurting for so long
and they finally made a decision
and there's a piece for the first time
in a long long time
suicide does not result from people who
are weak or of more of who have no
character who are cowards you just don't
have the willpower but
people are hurting people who are in
pain
and one thing that i think is super
important to call out so there's been a
lot of studies on the um golden gate
bridge out in the glengate bridge in san
francisco
the idea and i've thought this too
there's a guy who lived in this world i
thought this too
that if you
you know someone's gonna take their life
someone's gonna die by suicide
if i stop them if we call in 9-1-1 and
we get everybody involved we take the
guns out of the house or the knives out
of the house they're just gonna find
another way to do it they're just gonna
they're gonna figure out another way
and what we learned from
the golden gate bridge is there's this
people who jump off the bridge
and they live
and i think of i think it's 94 of the
people who jumped
have nothing left to live for
i'm out i'm done
and they live
they survive the jump
94 of the people who jump go on to live
full lives
only six percent ended up finding
another way to take their life
what does that tell us
get in the middle of it
stop somebody from making this choice
and if you'll get in the middle of it if
you will ask somebody are you gonna hurt
yourself
you will not do this on my watch i'm
calling 9-1-1 i'm going to send
everybody i'm calling your mom
40 year old i don't care calling
everybody i'll call the police i'll call
anybody i'm going to get in the middle
of it i'm coming over to your house
right now
young people who are listening to this
hey you promise you won't tell but i've
been thinking about
i've been thinking about uh taking all
of all of this or all of that
sorry i said i wouldn't tell but i am
telling that i'm telling everybody
telling the school counselor and telling
all my coaches i'm telling everybody
because i'm not going down on that ship
with you
because if i can help you be okay
tomorrow and then maybe the next day
maybe the next day get the help and care
that you need over time
then i get to go to your wedding and
then i get to hug your grandkids
a couple of warning signs real quick
threatening to harm or kill yourself i
take that thing real seriously i wish i
wasn't here i wish i was just dead i'm
sorry i'm such a i'm sorry i'm just
gonna head out i'm gonna head out
because so much better if i'm not here
talking about death all the time
relating strongly with other suicides
man that sounds so great like i've been
thinking about that
people who box themselves into there's
no way out there's no way out there's no
way out
talking about being a burden like we
talked about earlier
just
strange isolation or withdrawal or
loneliness nobody understands me i'm all
by myself
mood or behavioral changes people start
giving stuff away
deep deep depression or anxiety and
again all these things isolated man
absolutely doesn't mean people are going
to take their own life
all in fact the things i'm expressing i
felt those myself at seasons or another
and that's what other people are for you
cool man you all right yeah i'm cool i'm
just i'm struggling hey you go talk to
somebody dude and i've had people in my
life other grown men other college age
friends who have reached out and said
hey you can call somebody
and i've never once been what i would
call suicidal but i've been not okay
agitation aggression irritability
increased substance use especially
self-medication right these are all
just little windows into somebody's soul
and are you all right are you all right
are you all right
and like i told everybody else don't
hide grief from each other don't hide
the fear from each other don't don't
don't not have hard conversations
the time has come for all of us start
having conversations
and remember if somebody in your world
does take their life
it's not your fault
it's not your fault we'll be right back
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
so go to johndaloney.com to take the
next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show the songs by frank turner
it's a song you wrote for his friend who
died by suicide listen to the words
frank writes
why didn't you call my phone's always on
why didn't you call before you were gone
and i can't say for certain what i would
have said but now i'm a helplessly
silent instead and there's a hole in my
heart and a hole in my head why didn't
you call why didn't you say something
there's always hope left and i can't say
for certain what i would have done
but i can't do anything now that you're
gone
and it kills me for a second you it
kills me to think for a second you felt
alone
and i know you were carrying too much
weight on the evening when you slipped
away but i loved you like a brother and
i never had a chance to say so at half
past nine each evening
i'll think of my friend
you were better than your end because i
too have stood up on that ledge but i
know you would have pulled me back down
from that edge and i let you down in the
darkness and i wasn't there so i'll
remember you making a hole through the
kids in the crowd and i'll remember you
lifting me up each time i fell down
that's what i'll whisper to myself
next time i see that hole in the crowd
brother i miss you like hell this has
been the dr john dolone show
coming up on the next episode well
that's the first well
how honest can i be oh 100
are you positive oh yeah
the type of yelling you're describing is
abuse
and it is trauma it's just hard for me
to do that and then also go and get my
exercise or do the things that i also
need to do in order to function how
close are you to
just walking out the door
something about his past it says
marriage is not safe somebody else isn't
safe this is become this interaction
with mom he totally controls interesting
feels like a warm blanket for him his
ex-wife
walked out on him
all coming together james we should
start a podcast